the moments in our movies that stand out
that uh
that still scare me the moment when
katie throws mika at the camera at the
end of paranormal activity the films
inside of sinister and particularly the
one with the parents hanging
but all of the 16 millimeter films in
sinister
i find those incredibly unnerving and
disturbing they certainly make me jump
i certainly recoil from the violence in
halloween
and more recently the moment where the
throat is slit and the invisible man
when the two women are at the restaurant
that moment is still incredibly
unnerving and i flinch every time i see
that
hey my name is jason blum and i'm going
to be talking to gq today
about some of my favorite and scariest
moments
in a bunch of blumhouse movies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is the moment of paranormal
activity it's mika's mika's
frame his famous frame looking at the
bed
and this was actually a reshoot that we
did so we got involved with this movie
oren had sent a rough cut to us i
thought it was
very special but but uh he wanted to
make some improvements and it was very
inexpensive so we did a bunch of
different
improvements along the way and one of
them was actually this scene and this is
the scene where you're looking at the
bed
we think the ghost takes this sheet and
pulls it slowly off the bed and it kind
of disappears
in the corner of the room what actually
happened is the crew on this movie
as as as you probably know was like two
people
and so now that i was there was three
people and actually we were on the set
and someone else is going to do it and i
said oren please let me do it i want to
pull the sheet
and uh and he let me do it and i lay
down in the very corner of the room
and oren said go and the sheet slowly
moved across the bed it was the cheapest
most practical scary effect ever done
[Applause]
i came today because last night i had a
dream about this place
i was in this house but it was late at
night
insidious was our follow-up to
paranormal activity and it was directed
by the amazing
james juan and lee wannell wrote it and
they had come up with saw
they worked in various capacities on all
the soul movies and
uh this is before james wan was quite
the superstar he is today
although he was just as talented he was
just wasn't as well known
and um i learned a ton about scary
movies from james wan a ton i remember
just as an aside a funny story
when we first screened the movie people
weren't jumping
and i looked at james i said what's
wrong i had no idea what was wrong but i
just knew that it wasn't as scary as
james promised it would be and jane said
jason i know exactly what to do give me
two weeks he said another screening
it looked like the same exact movie and
people were jumping out of their seats
and he had just adjusted the timing
of all the scares and what i learned
from james is that the timing of
a scare is as important as the timing of
a joke and you could not even be aware
it can be the same dialogue the same
images the same everything else
but if the timing isn't exactly right
the scares just don't work
so in this particular scare which i
think is one of the best scares in the
movie joseph bashar
who actually did all the music for
insidious which is amazing
put this very simple demon face on and i
remember when we were on the set
just thinking have doubting james as
usual thinking like
this looks like super campy and like
this is not going to be scary and when
he did it it
wasn't scary at all on the side which
just goes to show you james has every
right instinct and i have every wrong
one
the one choice i did make that was right
was i believed in my filmmaker and we
always do that's the one thing
i've learned over the years is to bet on
our filmmakers anyway
james put this thing together he did
that first screening and it was like oh
we're not quite there and then the
second screening there were
10 great moments but that's maybe my
favorite because
it's so simple and so effective and it
was all because of the brilliance of
james wan
i can still hear that voice
[Music]
what do i do you're going to cover the
other side of the house
all right this is our home our kids live
here anybody tries to come in you blast
them you will not hesitate
the purge also uh holds a special place
in my heart
the key to our business in 2012 and
today
is we like we look for big concepts
high concept we say in low budget
usually big concept movies or high
concept movies are expensive it's very
hard to find
a big idea that could be done very
inexpensively and what i loved about the
purge was
it was the ultimate high concept low
budget movie
from seven to seven all crime is legal
there's total anarchy america is
crazy but we're gonna tell it from the
point of view
of a single family inside a house and
actually that made it even scarier
and that's really what i loved initially
about the uh the concept of the purge
you're mr mitchus i'm sorry to tell you
this but your time
is essentially up
and you failed you failed to deliver
the homeless swine
so i bit the bird well sweet sandy
release the beast boys let the killing
commence one of the things james
demonico did so well with the purge is
he strung out the story so if it was a
hollywood version of the of the purge
the bad guys would have broken into the
house on page nine but i don't think it
happens in the purge until we're almost
almost halfway through the movie
and uh the result of that is that you've
got
comfortable with this the family's very
comfortable they have all these
safeguards they
they've been through many purges before
and the audience kind of relaxes
enough time has gone by in the film that
you kind of think
no one's ever getting in this house i
mean after all the father his job is
selling security systems for houses
you've got to assume he's got the best
security system you can buy
and i think one of the most effective
scenes in the purge is when the
outside world finally comes inside to
the house
and you know super bad things are going
to happen
and um and and the the part of the
brilliance of that moment is where it
comes in the actual movie
[Music]
[Music]
this movie was so good i'd always wanted
to make a movie with knight because he
he's one of the great genre filmmakers
of our time and i also thought he would
really thrive in our system
it's really an auteur system we give the
filmmaker total creative control
and when i first read the script of
split
um the connection to
uh unbreakable and glass was not in it
that last scene wasn't in the script and
the movie
worked great as a standalone movie and
it really wasn't until much later on
that knight told me that he was going to
make it part of this trilogy
and there was even a rights issue like
there was a we had to make it work both
ways we had to make it work
independently
um and we also had to make it work as
part of the three movies in case he
couldn't figure out the right situation
which he did
and he kept that he never circulated a
script with that last coda
which connects it to the other two
movies and even when we screened the
movie um we were very careful a lot of
the times we screened the movie we left
that part out
so the secret would uh would remain safe
until the film opened and
miraculously even though even after
screening it at south by southwest
the secret stayed until opening weekend
which was incredible
the creepiest moment in that movie
although there are a lot is when
is when kevin dies and i guess i guess
that's
a real um tribute to kind of knight's
storytelling because
it's a dialogue scene it's not action
nothing happens no one jumps out there's
not a scare
but the words and the the the the
content of what he's saying
is so um surprising and disarming
and you start to catch up kill me
and kill me
[Music]
don't do that don't do that he can't
handle reality
my name is jade has dr fletcher been
getting our emails
the great thing about split is that
knight keeps the audience
just far enough behind the story that
you're kind of on the edge of your seat
and that's a moment where he brings you
closer up to the action that's actually
happening
at the time on screen and uh
it's just an incredibly effective moment
in the film
what about your mother
what about her wait are we where were
you when she died
i don't want to think about that when i
first read the script of get out
i uh i remember thinking kind of it
checks every box for
uh for the for the kind of movie that
we're looking for so with the company
what i look for is the movie has to
scare me or be unnerving
um it has to be able to be shot
relatively inexpensively which that was
possible with get out
we look for originals and originality
and there was
more of that baked into every page of
get out
than than maybe maybe any other film or
television project we ever did
and um i read it i loved it i met with
jordan
and i wanted to make sure that um
because the movie is about
a lot of things but it's obviously about
race and i wanted to make sure i was
comfortable
talking with the director about race and
that jordan would be comfortable talking
about it too because clearly
that was something we were going to have
to do if we were going to endeavor to
make this movie together
and i remember being incredibly imp
impressed with jordan
all across the board in in terms of his
grasp of the script and his super super
specific vision
and though he'd never directed before
he'd been a show runner which i think in
a lot of ways is harder than a director
so he was fully equipped
to direct this movie um and could talk
about race very easily
and uh and we had a great first meeting
and we were off to the races
now one of the most unsettling moments
they're bigger i think they're bigger
kind of
jump scare moments in get out but one of
the most unnerving moments
is when uh when catherine keener
hypnotizes daniel and she's slowly
stirring the teacup
and i think what's so spectacular about
that moment is
jordan has set it up in such a way that
you kind of think like
these people are pretty creepy and
pretty awful and you kind of think like
her steering the teacup like
nothing's really gonna like she's just
bananas and it works
and he's hypnotized and i think that in
itself is shocking enough and then the
fact that you see how he's hypnotized
and what him falling
into the sunken place which is done
incredibly simply and elegantly but it's
incredibly unsettling because you think
these people are off their rockers
and the fact that she's able to do this
makes you suddenly feel that
you're worried about daniel's life and
um
and that these guys these guys may be
really evil and uh
and they're it's gonna be very very hard
to overcome and really really hard to
literally get out of the house my
personal favorite moment in get out
is when you realize um that the
character played by alison williams is
uh
is not what she appears and in fact
she's evil just like her mother and
father
and that happens uh when daniel
discovers inside this kind of cubbyhole
attic kind of space these old
photographs where where alison has had a
series of black boyfriends and it's very
clear
that she's going out with daniel because
he's black
and um it's clear that she has a plan
for him
which is going to be similar to the plan
for her 10 past
ex-boyfriends and it's the moment when
he realizes
it's not just her parents who are weird
but she is too
and and i think what makes that moment
so effective is most
most people including me when i read the
script just
don't see that coming you don't see any
of that coming
um and jordan just so cleverly
orchestrates everything if you watch the
movie again you can throw all these
tells but the first time i read it or
the first time you see the film
you really don't know or you're not sure
that she's bad until that moment
um and you have the realization along
with danielle and it's uh
one it's probably my favorite moment in
the movie
[Music]
okay are you ready
happy birthday thanks but i already
ate it last night
what
you killed me chris land is one of my
favorite favorite filmmakers we've
worked with him on
a bunch of movies we met on paranormal
activity two and he worked on two
three four and he's working if we ever
get this reboot up he's working on the
new
new incarnation of paranormal activity
whatever that may be most of the movies
that we've made
aren't new brand new ideas that come out
they're movies that haven't really been
able to find a home and have been lying
around for a while and happy death day
was one of those movies i think
it had been i forget was it was called
something else but it had been written
four or five years before we made it and
i loved it i loved everything about it
and
uh there's one moment it's very confused
i think one of the fun things about the
movie is
you don't really know what's happening
and the moment the tree
actually figures out um who is
who is killing her and why she killed
her or how she killed her
you have these series of revelations and
chris goes to these flashbacks the
things that you've seen through the
course of the movie
that now suddenly in this scene makes
sense to the audience at the exact same
time they make sense to tree and um
and that's a uh that's a terrific scene
in the movie because chris is able to
tie up
all these things that seem to be not
connected in this really really elegant
way
[Music]
you've reached the colorado springs
chapter of the ku klux klan please leave
a message
and god bless white america jordan and i
were
in my office and we were we were meeting
spike to talk to him about
you know his desire to do black mansman
and it was really one of the
most exciting meetings i certainly ever
had spike lee has been one of my heroes
since i
first started i made a movie called
kicking and screaming
that noah boundback uh directed many
many years ago
and one of the one of the directors we
talked about having a successful career
an
independent film and the success if
she's gotta have it was was spike lee
and i never met him before so anyway
here he was sitting in my office talking
about uh
how he was gonna direct black klansmen
it was awesome it was amazing we said
yes yes yes yes yes a hundred times
john david who plays ron stallworth who
was there and i met ron and uh
ron actually had that had his kkk card
at a reading we did we did a reading of
the of the script at uh
at spike's office in brooklyn and there
was ron and he passed his
kkk card around and i will tell you that
my favorite scene from the movie is when
he actually calls
the the the k the head of the kkk
and and they believe him what's your
story
well since you asked
since you asked i hate i hate jews
spicks and mix dagos and chinks
but my mouth to god's ears i really hate
those
and anyone else really that doesn't have
pure white aryan blood running through
their veins
i will say that when you read it it just
it doesn't have the same impact but when
you see a black man
calling the head of the kkk and them
having this very
um friendly conversation um
it's a great example of how in story
storytelling in movies like that
10 second or 15 second phone call
just says more about
how stupid the kkk is and ignorant
and backwards than almost anything else
you could do
and it was such a simple moment and such
a spectacular moment and a moment that
could only work in a film
you were just the kind of guy that we
are looking for
listen uh when can you meet not about
friday night after i get off work
that's the deal buddy boy we'll get
right back to you with the details take
care now
god bless white america it didn't really
work in ron's book it didn't really work
in the script you don't
the power of it is only seen when you
can
see it um and that by far is uh
certainly my favorite moment in uh in
black klansmen
did i just hear you use your real name
oh [ __ ]
i sent an email to david gordon green's
a great filmmaker i've always admired
him i sent him an email and i
was one word it's a halloween question
mark and
he wrote me back he said i think he said
i'm in i think that's what he said
or something close to that and uh and
that that was the beginning of of the
new
the new iteration of halloween and
neither neither david or i wanted to do
without john carpenter and so we went to
john and asked him to participate and be
an executive producer with us and i'm
very glad he said yes because if he
hadn't said yes i don't think either one
of us would have made the movie so it
was it was amazing and we got jamie lee
curtis back and
just really fun to do and the fan base
around halloween is very
rabid so we were you know concerned
about making it new but also
not making a mistake and i think david
did an amazing job in the movie and
and obviously the biggest moment in that
movie is when uh
when we think jamie lee curtis has
finally gotten
after 45 years has finally gotten her
revenge on michael myers and finally
been able to kill michael myers and that
happens right
at the end of the movie when he's
trapped in the basement and she uh
she throws the fire in and shuts the
shuts this trapdoor
and uh and we're led to believe that he
uh he burns to that
that was uh maybe the culmination of 45
how many years 45 or 50 years of uh
of halloween
[Music]
kayla
so we did the live with venusoud who's
who was you know one of my favorite one
of my favorite directors i had a general
meeting with her and i said we want to
do anything you want to do and not that
long after she gave me the script of the
lie
um which i loved i loved it because it
was so relatable
it just it just poses the question how
far would you go to protect your child
how many laws would you break what would
you do to protect your child
where's your friend where is he where's
your friend
that question is posed at the very very
beginning of the movie so this is the
scene
which i think is the most um talked
about because it sets up that question
at the very beginning of the film when
peter skarsgard finds
uh the character played by joey king on
the bridge
and joey admits to her dad
what she's done
you kind of see the whole next 90
minutes of the movie
on her dad's face because you see his
wheels turning and you see him
starting to make little decisions little
twist to the truth
which i think everyone knows for no
other reason it's the beginning of the
movie
are going to grow and and that's a lot
of what the movie is about
is that one lie begets another and a
smaller libby gets a bigger lie
but again you the the great fun thing
about the movie or the interesting thing
about the movie is it's the one
instance or one of the few instances you
can really forgive someone for lying to
a certain point
then it gets uh it gets out of control
but i think i think the reason that's
the most effective moment in the movie
is because it sets up the premise of
what you're about to see
veena does such a good job of building
to that place
that even though you understand why
they're doing it
you realize at that point that these
people are
are out of their minds
thank you so much gq for uh letting me
talk about a few
of uh my favorite moments from uh from a
small handful of our movies
but there are many more to come